house of the dragon episode two has a
dragon showdown two awkward marriage
proposals and the reveal of cragas crab
feeder so what's going on and what does
it mean this video has no spoilers
beyond hotd episode 2.
it starts with a new opening sequence
for the series it shows a model city
like the one viserys makes but with a
stream of blood running through it this
represents the bloodline of house
targaryen it's a family tree showing the
last hundred years of targaryen kings it
starts with this image of valyria the
old empire of the dragonlords valyria
was destroyed in the mysterious doom but
the targaryens survived because they had
already left valyria and come to
dragonstone in westeros this next image
is of aegon's conquest when aegon
targaryen and his sisters and their
dragons took over westeros here the
bloodline splits in two because aegon
had one son with his sister wife rhaenys
and one son with his other sister wife
visenya the rhaenys symbol shows a
dragon skull with a bolt through the eye
because rhaenys and her dragon were shot
down with a scorpion bolt in dawn
rhaenys's bloodline continues on to her
son king aenes aegon's other son maegor
also became king but he never had
children and so isn't included in this
bloodline
after maegor aenes's son jaehaerys
became king and he married his sister
alisain here the bloodline splits into
nine streams because joharis and
alisaine had nine children who survived
to adulthood next are jaehaerys's kids
baelon and alyssa balon has a hand
symbol because balon was hand of the
king baelon and alyssa's son was king
viserys viserys married emma aaron and
she's got the aaron sigil
after emma is a long stream of blood
which evokes emma's stillbirths and
miscarriages and her death but then we
see her daughter rhaenyra with the
symbol of the valyrian steel necklace
that daemon gave her last episode and
there's an image of the ceremony where
rhaenyra was named heir to the throne
meanwhile in the background we see the
bloodline of the velaryons shown with
blue symbols and we see the bloodline of
otto hightower with his hand of the king
symbol and his daughter alicent with the
hightower sigil so this new intro is a
visual summary of the targaryen family
alongside the velaryons and hightowers
maybe the intro will change throughout
the season as the family changes because
this season occasionally jumps forward
in time several years the blood imagery
reminds us that the history of the royal
family is written in the blood of birth
and the blood of battle and in a lot of
red wine
the bloodline is running downhill which
suggests the targaryens are in decline
falling from their peak at valyria down
towards fiery disaster
the episode starts about six months
after the previous episode we see that
krager's crab feeder has attacked
another westerosi ship crab feeder is
the leader of the triarchy an alliance
of eastern cities who have taken over
the stepstone's islands cragus is called
crab feeder because he nails his enemies
to the beach so they get eaten alive by
crabs
according to a behind the scenes video
crab feeder has greyscale greyscale is a
disease that slowly turns the body into
stone we saw stone men infected with
greyscale in game of thrones jorah
mormont catches greyscale greyscale can
eventually cause madness so it looks
like the disease makes the crab feeder
crazy and dangerous
he wears a mask similar to the sons of
the harpy mask from game of thrones the
idea is that crab feeder created his
outfit from bits and pieces that he
found in shipwrecks
crab feeders attacks are disrupting the
trade that makes corliss velaryon rich
so corliss wants to attack crab feeder
immediately but king viserys doesn't
want a big war so he sends diplomats to
the eastern cities of pentos and
volantis to see if they'll help against
the triarchy and this might actually be
a smart move getting the free cities to
sort this out amongst themselves so that
the targaryens don't have to go to war
but caller says that this makes the
targaryens look weak and rhaenyra
suggests that they should send dragon
riders as a show of force everyone's
talking back to king viserys and
questioning him but when rhaenyra speaks
up viserys and otto shut her down and
send her away rhaenyra feels frustrated
that even though she's the heir to the
throne she's not allowed to participate
in politics
she is still just the cup bearer and
viserys still treats her like a little
girl
ryam redwine the commander of the
kingsguard has died of natural causes
and there are always seven kingsguard so
now they need a new member to replace
ryam otto chooses candidates from houses
karen mallister corbray rowan krakow and
tarly how starly is the family of sam
and randall in game of thrones each
candidate is represented by a carved
model kind of like the small council
balls and viserys's dragon statue
suggesting that everyone here is just a
piece in a game of thrones
otto tells rhaenyra to say polite
courtesies to the knights so she plays
that role with a fake fleeting smile
this is what's expected of a young lady
smiles and courtesies but rhaenyra has
more to offer otto says they should
choose the malista or cray-call knight
for the kingsguard because those houses
are important politically but the
kingsguard are meant to be apolitical
and unbiased simply the best most
honorable knights in the realm when the
kingsguard are chosen for political
reasons instead that can make the
kingsguard weaker by the time of game of
thrones most of the kingsguard aren't
great knights instead they're corrupt
cronies cowards and oath breakers
rhaenyra wants her father's guards to
actually be great fighters so she
chooses kristin cole because he has real
battle experience and because he's
really hot
king viserys and alison hightower have a
hangout date meeting and viserys talks
about valyria the old dragonlord empire
the valyrian capital city was built on
volcanoes called the 14 flames and
viserys says the volcanoes were the
source of valyrian magic and power the
books say that all valyrian sorcery was
rooted in blood or fire their sorcerers
used glass candles that let them see
across the world and enter people's
dreams viserys says the valyrian blood
mages lived in the inogrion anogre
apparently means blood in valyrian the
books say that valyrian blood mages did
some crazy messed up [ __ ] they twisted
the flesh of beasts and men to create
monstrous chimeras in the flesh pits of
gorgosos beasts were mated to slave
women to bring forth twisted half-human
children some fans theorized that
valyrian blood magic created dragons and
gave the targaryens the dragon
dragonblood that allows them to control
dragons
in this episode we see a painting on a
wall of a dragon having sex with humans
the blood of the dragon may be literal
but viserys doesn't mention valyria's
blood magic monstrosities or the fact
that valyria's volcanoes were full of
slaves being worked to death in the
burning mines it's crazy how viserys
admires the glory of valyria when
valyria was so evil it's like he's
playing with a lego model of magic nazi
germany viserys and alison compare
valyria and its fall to westeros and
then viserys drops a statue of a dragon
which heavily foreshadows disaster for
the targaryen dynasty
viserys and alison have been having
these meeting hang dates for a while on
one level it's an innocent friendship
alison understands vasaris's grief for
his dead wife emma because her own
mother died so she feels real sympathy
for viserys but at the same time alison
visits viserys because otto tells her to
he wants her to hook up with the king to
make the hightowers more powerful
alison's actor said it's ambiguous to
what extent alison is scheming for otto
instead of being genuine but ultimately
alison is a 14 year old girl who has to
obey her father and her king
we can see how anxious that makes her
feel when she picks at her fingernails
the relationship is further complicated
by alison's friendship with rhaenyra
because viserys tells alison not to tell
rhaenyra about their meetings which
forces alison to choose between loyalty
to her king and loyalty to her best
friend
alicent and rhaenyra go to a sept which
is a church of the faith of the seven
alicent is a believer of the faith which
makes sense because her family the
hightowers of old town have close ties
with the faith but rhaenyra is not so
religious some targaryens don't worship
gods preferring to think of themselves
as gods so alison teaches rhaenyra to
pray at the statue of the mother to feel
close to their own dead mothers alicent
and rhaenyra clearly have a deep bond
but when they talk about viserys
remarrying alison doesn't tell rhaenyra
about her meetings with viserys so
alison is not being completely honest
with her friend
viserys speaks with lord corliss and his
wife rhaenys who say that the targaryen
throne looks vulnerable crab feeder has
the stepstones daemon has dragonstone
queen emma is dead and the heir to the
throne is a girl corliss uses a sailing
metaphor about facing a storm because
corliss is a famous sailor who has
traveled the world corliss proposes that
king viserys marry his daughter lena to
make the royal family stronger by
deepening the targaryen velaryon
alliance this alliance has been shaky
ever since rhaenys was rejected at the
harrenhal council marrying lena to the
king who would bring them closer and
would make corliss even more powerful
but viserys is not keen to marry a 12
year old girl and he's still grieving
his dead wife emma so viserys appears
indecisive and uncertain which is really
not how a king should behave
viserys and rhaenyra try to talk and
connect but it's awkward the silence is
highlighted by the sound of crickets and
by the physical distance between viserys
and rhaenyra a table
rhaenyra brings up the council earlier
she wants viserys to listen to what she
has to say but viserys just talks over
rhaenyra again
we see that viserys's finger is rotting
after it was cut on the iron throne last
episode this is another bad omen hinting
that power is killing viserys that the
throne is rejecting him
the rotting hand also suggests that the
hand of the king otto is corrupt seeing
maggots eat his flesh evokes for saris's
line last episode about crows feasting
on his family's corpses this political
world is eating the ceres alive and two
of the hungriest vultures are otto and
melos
vaseris says that corliss proposed
marriage to lena and this worries otto
because he wants viserys to marry his
daughter allison otto shares some
knowing looks with grand maester melos
it's obvious that these two are working
together we saw them conniving in the
shadows last episode and saw a maester
whispering in otto's ear
it makes sense that otto might be
working with the maesters because the
maesters are based in the hightower city
of old town otto even wears a chain on
his neck that's similar to a maester's
chain
so together otto and melos subtly
manipulate viserys saying yes there are
good reasons to marry laina velaryon but
that would also anger rhaenyra and it
would be an insult to the memory of
viserys's dead wife so without saying it
directly or seeming biased otto and
melos pressure viserys not to marry
elena
facerus and lena have an awkward walk of
courtship in the garden like sansa's
awkward walks with loras in game of
thrones lena and viserys are both very
uncomfortable with this marriage
proposal though big age gaps in
political marriages are not uncommon in
westeros like in the books sansa is 12
when she marries tyrion and daenerys is
13 when she marries drogo
girls are considered ready to have sex
when they have their first period here
lena says she's expected to have sex
with viserys when she turns 14. the
books emphasize the horror that sansa
and daenerys experience as child brides
and show the danger of young pregnancies
in this world girls bodies are political
objects used to perpetuate bloodlines
just as men's bodies are on battlefields
lena is not interested in marriage she's
interested in dragons she asks about
vega the oldest and biggest dragon in
the world
ever since the death of viserys's dragon
balerion the black dread veigar was the
dragon of queen vicenia targaryen who
conquered westeros alongside aegon then
vega was ridden by balon targaryen the
father of viserys and daemon these days
the old she dragon has left king's
landing and retired to some place on the
east coast as many older women do and
it's kind of terrifying that the
targaryens don't know where their most
dangerous weapon is it's yet another
thing that king viserys is not in
control of lena says the workers at
spice town sometimes hear vega's song
spice town is a trading port on
driftmark so maybe the velaryons could
find vega
rhaenyra sees her father on a date with
a 12 year old if viserys remarries and
has a son that son could replace
rhaenyra as heir to the throne just like
rhaenys was replaced at the harrenhal
council when viserys was made heir
instead of her rhaenys says that this is
the order of things men would sooner put
the realm to the torch than see a woman
on the throne in game of thrones we see
how hard it is for daenerys and cersei
to hold power though to be fair it is
daenerys and cersei who torch the realm
not the men
rhaenys has mixed feelings for rhaenyra
she feels sympathy that rhaenyra is
facing the same obstacles she faced but
she also feels a little jealousy or
spite as though she doesn't want
rhaenyra to succeed where rhaenys failed
but rhaenyra insists that she will
become queen and will make a new order a
more fair political system like when
daenerys says that she'll break the
wheel will rhaenyra succeed where
daenerys fails
we learn that viserys's brother prince
daemon has been living on dragonstone
for the last six months despite the fact
that viserys ordered daemon to go to the
vale to his estranged wife raya royce
daemon took his gold cloaks to
dragonstone even though the gold cloaks
are meant to be guarding king's landing
and now daemon does something even more
provocative he calls himself the
rightful heir to the throne instead of
rhaenyra and he says he's going to marry
his lover mazzaria even though daemon's
already married to raya royce the
targaryens and valyrians do have a
history of marrying multiple wives aegon
the conqueror married both his sisters
rhaenys and visenya but according to the
faith of the seven polygamy is a sin
king maegor went to war with the faith
when he married six wives and after that
disaster the targaryens stopped their
polygamous marriages if daemon brings
back that tradition he could reignite
this old conflict with the faith
and daemon also steals a dragon egg
cause traditionally the targaryens put a
dragon egg in the cradle of their babies
so that the dragon hatchling bonds with
the baby and daemon says that mazaria is
pregnant with his child but the specific
dragon egg that daemon stole is the egg
that was going to be prince balons
vasaris and emma's baby that was going
to be viserys heir daemon's heir for a
day speech was what started this fight
with viserys in the first place so in
one day daemon commits treason blasphemy
egg theft and insults viserys over his
dead baby again
forcing the king to take action he says
he'll go and face daemon himself but
then otto says he can't allow that it's
too dangerous viserys is the king but it
often seems like otto is the one in
charge
later viserys says i am your king and in
game of thrones we're told that any man
who must say i am the king is no true
king
otto goes to dragonstone and tells
daemon to surrender but daemon just asks
where's viserys the whole reason daemon
does all this is because he wants
attention and acknowledgement from his
brother
daemon faces kristen cole the knight who
defeated him at the tournament last
episode daemon calls kristen sir crispin
instead just like in game of thrones
when jaime calls dick on rickon
daemon is protected by his fierce and
freaky dragon caraxies so otto can't
defeat daemon without a lot of dudes
being barbecued but then rhaenyra turns
up on her dragon cyrax with her dragon
rhaenyra can't be bossed around by otto
anymore so she takes charge and
confronts daemon by calling himself heir
to the throne daemon undermines
rhaenyra's position as heir dragonstone
itself is traditionally the seat of the
heir to the throne so rhaenyra dares
daemon to kill her to take her place as
heir and it looks like daemon thinks
about it but for all his violence and
chaos daemon doesn't want to kill his
family so daemon gives up the dragon egg
the egg is kept in this hot container
because dragon eggs seem to like heat
daemon's lover mazaria is angry because
despite daemon's announcements mazaria
wasn't told that they were gonna be
married and mazzaria isn't pregnant she
says she can't get pregnant mazzaria
says that daemon's political games might
be fun for him but they could easily get
her killed
men like otto see mazzaria as a
disposable [ __ ] we saw in game of
thrones how cersei and tywin treat women
they see as [ __ ]
mazzaria says she's been sold as
property and lived in terror most of her
life it's a similar backstory to
melisandre's in game of thrones who was
also a slave from the east who learned
how to survive we saw melisandre with
stannis brooding on dragonstone much
like mazaria and daemon on dragonstone
both stannis and daemon want the throne
and want the love of their older brother
viserys goes to lionel strong and asks
for unbiased advice viserys knows that
callus and otto are trying to use him
for their political gain so he asks
lionel for an outside opinion on who
viserys should marry
lionel says he should marry lena because
corliss is an important ally and they'll
need his ships if there's war in the
stepstones but lionel also says that
proud men don't like having to look up
and he says that while lionel is looking
up at viserys lionel is the lord of
harrenhal the biggest castle in the
realm and he's the leader of how strong
an ancient line of noble warriors
surely lionel is a proud man too
so what are his ambitions
viserys gets angry that rhaenyra flew
off to dragonstone without his
permission viserys feels very protective
of rhaenyra maybe because his wife died
he's terrified of losing his daughter
too but rhaenyra points out that she got
results she got the dragon egg without
any violence so she wants to show
viserys that he can trust in her
abilities viserys acknowledges that he
does need to let rainier grow into an
adult rhaenyra says that she understands
that as king vaseris needs to remarry so
for the first time in months viserys and
rhaenyra really connect emotionally but
there is a misunderstanding here because
rhaenyra thinks viserys is talking about
marrying lana velaryon but really
viserys is thinking of marrying alicent
rhaenyra's best friend
alicent fixes viserys's broken dragon
statue so maybe viserys thinks that
alison can fix his broken family or he
just wants a wife who supports his dorky
hobbies or maybe he'd just rather marry
a 14 year old rather than a 12 year old
either way the next day viserys
announces that he'll marry alice and
hightower and this pisses off everybody
except otto corliss is furious because
by rejecting lena the targaryens have
rejected his family again rhaenyra is
upset because it's super weird that her
dad is marrying her friend and also
because viserys and alicent kept their
relationship secret from her alicent
looks anxious about marrying this old
guy and becoming the queen and daemon
will be angry because a child of viserys
could push him further back in the line
of succession viserys's failure to
communicate with rhaenyra and to appease
corliss creates huge divisions at a time
when the targaryens are already looking
vulnerable
daemon and corliss get together on
driftmark the velaryon island kolas's
home is decorated with maps and skulls
and a barnacled bust artifacts from
corliss's sea voyages corliss and daemon
are both angry at viserys so they decide
to go do their own thing and to attack
the crab feeder to end the threat to
call us as ships and to win glory for
them both
corliss says house velaryon have always
been underdogs even back in valyria the
targaryens had dragons but the velaryons
didn't so they had to make their own
power with ships and grit
corlis is a self-made man in that it was
his voyages around the world that made
his family rich
corliss mentions building his seat by
his own strength cause corliss used his
wealth to build a new castle on
driftmark called high tide he also
mentions the driftwood throne which is
the seat of the lord of driftmark
according to legend the ancient
driftwood throne was given to the
velaryons by the merlin king
corlis says he and daemon must prove
their worth because they are second sons
the laws of inheritance in westeros mean
that firstborn sons like viserys inherit
the lordships and lands second sons like
daemon and otto often inherit nothing so
they've got to find their own place in
the world some second sons join the
maesters or the faith or the night's
watch some become tournament knights or
mercenaries there's a whole mercenary
group called the second sons who joined
daenerys in game of thrones in the books
oberyn martell and later tyrion join the
second sons
some second sons are jealous and
resentful of their big brothers like
stannis with his brother robert damon is
a classic example of a second son who
feels overshadowed by his brother
corliss is not literally a second son as
far as we know but house velaryon has
always been the second family in
westeros they've always been less
powerful than the royal targaryens so
kolas and daemon decide to prove
themselves by going to war with the crab
feeder
so in this episode divisions deepen
between the most powerful people in the
realm setting the stage for fiery
conflicts in the future
house of the dragon is based on the book
fire and blood season 1 covers chapter
12 heirs of the dragon there's also a
shorter summary of the story in the book
the world of ice and fire starting in
the viserys chapter so if you want to
know the full story of house of the
dragon from beginning to end with all
the spoilers you can get either of these
on audiobook for free right now at
audible.com asx sign up for a premium
plus trial membership and you get an
audio book to keep even if you cancel
the trial you can get any game of
thrones book or lord of the rings or
dune
membership also includes unlimited
access to thousands of audio books and
shows in the audible plus catalog sign
up at audible.com asx or text asx to 500
500. thanks for watching we're doing a
house of the dragon livestream every
sunday at about 10 15 p.m eastern time
and doing an explained video like this
one each week so like and subscribe
press the bell follow the twitter and
thanks to the supporters on patreon
including marina julius biggie smalls
the bog queen chris brodie franks babe
carly childress and coffee rz
cheers
you